what's amazing is that when guys go all
in in the first round even if they're in
great shape sometimes they don't recover
enough to complete the fight
right if the guy they're fighting is
skilled enough to not allow them that
yeah you know if you roll with a blue
belt you'll never get tired
he doesn't have the skill to make me
work right however if i'm with a black
belt
and i get exhausted and now he's making
me work right
i may never recover right right yeah
that's a it's well it's not just
it's also the way you go
out if you go out full clip in that
first round you
you have essentially sprinted yourself
into a position where you're just
so diminished there's so many fighters
that are like that right
like conor is kind of a good example
conor is fantastic
in the beginning of a fight right but
man he gets them third fourth and fifth
rounds and
he takes like the nate diaz fight the
second fight he becomes a human
he turned and walked away from him i
mean he was very human he needed that
break
so badly when you see that do you think
that that is a case of
and i don't want you to give away too
much because you know george potentially
wants to fight correct
right right do you think that that's
a case of poor conditioning do you think
that is
a lack of experience in handling those
moments because he's so used to
overwhelming people and taking them out
early
what do you think that is i think it's
partly genetic
really yes because you see i call it the
touch of death you know he's got that
left hand it's the touch of death
yeah that touch of death comes at a cost
okay how do you have the touch of death
where does power come from okay well if
you look at michael cogan what we're
talking about earlier he has
he has a criteria for power to the best
of his knowledge this is where he
believes power comes from
okay so i can't teach hussein ball to be
powerful i can only make him
faster but where did that initial power
come from
number one on the list number one is
where your muscle is attached to your
bone
it's genetic so tyson hits a he has a
powerful left hook not because his coach
taught him how to hit a left hook
he could have hit a left hook like that
if he had a mediocre trainer
it has to do with the leverage of his
bones so for instance
uh you know if i'm gonna imagine i had
like a like a
a really heavy pole that weighs 100
pound and i want to stand it up well
depending on where i grab it
i'm going to have more resistance or
less resistance if i grab it near the
end i have more leverage
so where your muscles attach to your
bone is gonna is gonna dictate how much
leverage you get out of it
second most important element is the
type of muscle fiber you have
the type so if you have a fast twitch
muscle fiber
you can hold less oxygen but it can
twitch faster hence the name
so if you're a slow twitch muscle fiber
guy you can
metabolize more oxygen but you can't
twitch as fast so there's a give and
take
neckties exactly so you have a guy nick
diaz who needs to knock you out with
volume
yeah he can't knock you out with one
shot like look at bj pen if round one he
doesn't knock you out likely hood of
knock you out in round two is less
right diaz is the opposite the
likelihood of him knocking on round
three is higher than round one
yeah because of the cumulative attack
yeah
mcgregor look at his stats it's all
around one knockout run one knockout
round round
round two knockout he's fast twitch high
leverage
left hand yeah if you take him into deep
waters
his fast twitch muscle fibers cannot
metabolize with mayweather maybe
they're so smart he let him work he let
mcgregor work for three rounds
yeah and you're getting excited keep
working keep working
and when you have nothing left i'm gonna
put you out you know that was such a
brilliant strategy
it was it was so obvious how much more
efficient he was
exactly you know and more relaxed conor
had his moments
early in the fight where he hit him with
some unorthodox punches and some
some weird movement but after a while
was just i found both of them had a
brilliant performance because what
mcgregor did to go in his world
oh incredible it was brilliant it was
brilliant just crazy
crazy that that it even happened really
stop and think about it it was almost
like the world got a magic trick
it was unbelievable i want george to
fight me weather i keep bothering you
fight me with her you
fight him he's like it's crazy i know
it's crazy but
i bet mayweather would do it that's what
i'm saying that's what i'm saying george
might have to lose a shitload of weight
yeah they'll find a catch weight do you
think mayweather is worried that he's
gonna get concussed he's fought all the
top punchers in the world
right he's just gonna have to worry
about george's volume and reach but he
can handle himself and george can handle
himself
but the whole world is gonna tune into
that one you know what i'm saying i like
george you're selling it
yeah george do it man do it but george
doesn't want to fight a smaller guy he
doesn't want to call out a smaller guy
so
it's going to have to come from
mayweather it's going to have to come
from wow
there's another big money fight yep but
is it a bit as big a money fight that's
the thing
the real big money fight is in somehow
or another
mcgregor convincing the world that he
could beat him in a second fight
like i know the weather yes oh that's a
hard sell it's a hard sell
we bought that one already yeah we
bought that one
we'll need george to fight mcgregor
there was the one thing of doing it in
the octagon
and doing it with small gloves and no
kicks remember there was
there was some talk of that and people
were like where's this talk coming from
i don't know if it was legit or not i
called dana dana said it's
100 yeah but because the state
can't enforce that
so if mcgregor wants to throw a kick
he'll throw a kick right
it'd have to be gentleman's rule